women think that having sex with a man
on the first date will bond him to her
but that doesn't work with secure men or
avoidant men it really only works with
crushingly insecure men who crave
approval and women don't want to bond
with those men men we don't we don't get
the same kind of hormone release that
women do and we don't process it the
same for us it's a lot more dopamine
it's not the same level of oxytocin
quite that they get so we are very
different women if they have an orgasm
with a man they're probably going to
bond with him this is why casual sex is
so so difficult for women and especially
maintaining friendships um and just
steady platonic or or casual Friends
with Benefits situations for women this
is why they turn Friends with Benefits
into situationships this is why this
happens they will start off agreeing one
thing then do the other you've probably
seen this before I'm sure um men don't
bond that way they don't they just don't
typically if there's already a bond
happening yes then having sex can be
unitive and it can make him love you and
and and not love you but make him care
for you more it can increase his
affection for you it can increase the
bonding but the connection already has
to be there you don't get a guy to fall
in love with you doing that so this
whole first date sleep with him on the
first date so he'll stay around that's a
whole other thing yeah I I wonder
whether it's women using their theory of
mind I think in The evolutionary
psychology literature it's called cross-
seex mind reading failures so um they
believe that if it was me the only way
that I would be able to sleep with
somebody is if I felt very deeply about
them therefore if this happens with the
man then this is how he must feel about
me and it's a failure of of using your
own theory of mind you're very right
it's also I've been studying a lot of
miring neurons especially when we're
little children so when we're born we
have the amydala and then we have a lot
of airing neurons it's it's two of the
only structures that are really fully
formed at Birth and our mirroring
neurons we're supposed to have mom mom
is supposed to be paying attention to us
and and looking at us and mirroring our
expression to her so that we we feel
interesting to people just by existing
and then when we make a face she mirrors
it back to us and we start mirroring
each other and we say other people will
respond to me I am enough if Mom doesn't
she's depressed she's tired she's
exhausted she's working three jobs and
is never there we're in daycare all the
time if we've had nicku trauma if we've
had various issues our brain says mom is
not mirroring me or or I can't get a
response I have to be interesting to get
Mom's attention this is where kids start
acting out a lot or they go Inward and
don't believe they can get any kind of
response the response tries dies the
desire to even connect so then people
are trying in dating to be interesting
they're trying to stimulate others women
say I have to sleep with them on the
first date or he'll lose interest when
you hear that her mother probably didn't
mirror with her correctly her father
didn't mirror with her correctly she
learned I have to be interesting and
stimulating guys same thing when they
try to dance for women's approval it's
that mirroring neurons all the way back
have you youve probably met guys like
this right that try to be interesting
instead of be
real yeah I think there's a a massive
lack of confidence and insecurity around
authenticity there's all manner of rumor
and halft truth and full truth and no
truth about vulnerability and when it's
right to open up and when you shouldn't
open up as a man and you know the
more layers of of Bro Science and and
half remembered heay that you layer on
on top of an interaction the more
performative it becomes the more Persona
and less person there is in the
interaction and the more that that
happens the less you actually feel
connected with what you're doing because
you're not connecting from you to a
person you're playing a role so even if
you do get the outcome that you want the
person isn't in love with you they're in
love with this projection that you've
given them and you know this is such a
it's such a dangerous Catch 22 to fall
into it's the reason I think
fundamentally that the actual hardcore
pickup World failed for men that were
unconfident with women because what it
taught them was that the person they had
to be and the person that they genuinely
were were so far apart if I need to go
through this massive rigal and say did
you see the fight with two midgets
outside isn't that and then I've got a
neger and like twist the lemon and I've
got to like you know ignore her and chat
up her friend and do all this [__] it's
like if I have to go through this
complex [__] rain dance to try and
get a woman to go to bed with me and
that's not what I would do what does
that say about me and you know it's it's
one of the problems of taking your cues
from culture as opposed from yourself
and again you know a lot of this could
come from parenting problems too it is
think of this there's from from what I
have found there are two different
dating pools and they don't flag or
signal to each other at all they have
almost no crossover they're not even
aware of each other there's the secure
people who want that direct human
authentic connection of we are together
we are talking we're sharing this Bond
they don't want stimulation because it
feels weird too much stimulation up
front feels weird to them they
understand that connection so they want
the right bonding experience then
there's the insecure pool that everybody
is trying to be interesting interesting
interesting and they're playing that
anxious or that avoidant dance over here
two different pools that never cross so
when you see guys every woman out there
expects you to be eight feet tall and
have an 18inch dick and you have to have
10 billion in the bank and no no you
don't and you don't have to dance for
her amusement and endlessly play games
or have dread game or control her that's
only going to work on those insecure
women over here it's never going to work
on secure women they will get up and
walk away you're going to look confusing
to them or disinterested and they're
going to track as confusing or
disinterested for you the two dating
pools are segregated out completely
according to this model it is wild to
see yeah and you know just to kind of
round out the women having sex on a
first date thinking that it'll get a man
to bond with
her I I I really really don't think that
many of the girls that listen to this
show will think that but if there is is
or if you've got a friend that does
think that
like price is an indicator of
quality and for almost all of human
history there was a a courting period
that needed to occur even if the
courting period was passive because you
lived in the same tribe together and she
observed you being competent and
reliable and trustworthy and bringing
back a big wilderbeast and helping out
with the whatever whatever right so
there is a period of of value uh
justification from man to woman and also
from woman to man and if you shortcut
that the presumption from a lot of guys
and I can tell you this from first and
secondhand experience if a woman gives
it up too easily the assumption is well
she'll do this to any
man correct that's that's the first
thing men think of that was a great
hamburger everyone is eating this
hamburger I'll come back when I'm hungry
but it's not the hamburger I'm going to
settle for every single morning for over
3 years now I've started my day the
exact same way which is with element in
water element contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of so sodium potassium
and magnesium and it is the best
hydration drink that I've ever found it
tastes fantastic it's super refreshing
orange is just the most OP flavor in the
world it's absolutely phenomenal and it
helps to play a critical role in
reducing muscle cramps and fatigue
regulates your appetite it optimizes
brain health and it helps curb Cravings
they're also the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
relied on by tons of Olympic athletes
and everyday High performers all around
the world also there is a no BS no
questions refund policy where you can
buy a box completely risk-free and if
you do not like it for any reason they
will give you a refund during an
unlimited duration and you don't even
need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it
element are giving away a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box if you go to the link in the
description box below or drink LM
n.com MW that's drink LM nt.com
SL MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe